what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
morning coffee thoughts although I don't
drink coffee anymore
um this is tea so
um
but before I start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and let's get
started so
I'm sick this week oh my gosh I'm so
irritated that I'm sick
I have been looking forward I'm going to
no jumper today
and I've been looking forward to this
interview for like months I'm so excited
I love no jumper
and now God decided to make me sick but
you know what sometimes in life you
persevere so
today I'm going to talk about censorship
and why
demonetizing videos like the entertain
interview
um makes it harder for creators like me
so
I knew that when I put Andrew Tate and
Brittany Renner in a panel together that
would break the internet
I knew and
I had this idea I loved and people ask
me like why did I pick Brittany Renner
she wasn't the only girl I reached out
to
but she was the first one and the reason
was because
I love it when you put two people in a
room that are on opposite ends of the
same issue I think that's the most
interesting so when you put in
you know a super left like Destiny let's
just say for I'm I try to avoid to
politics I'm more in relationships
politics I'll talk about a little bit
but it's not necessarily magnet Lane but
you know Destiny Ben Shapiro I would
love to see that
so I was trying to think of people that
kind of were the opposite of what red
pill the manosphere stands for whatever
plus you know I also thought she was
entertaining um
anyways so I knew that was gonna break
the internet and the thing that people
don't realize is when you're putting
together a video you kind of as a
Creator have to think
how much is this gonna cost right you
have to pay if they're big enough you
pay the people to come out there
um you I I have my own Studio but if we
had gone to Dubai we would have had to
pay for equipment to rent
um and I'm talking upwards
between the money I lost on Dubai I
probably spent over 10 grand putting
this video together
yeah
rough maybe a little less but
you think am I gonna make my money back
um because again this is a business at
the end of the day you're gonna go broke
if you don't make money on these videos
and so my thought was
okay put them together do the video I
think we'll make it back this will break
the internet the problem is when it gets
demonetized in the future it makes it
harder to put together similar videos
like for example we wanted to do a
Brittany Renner wife school with Andrew
Tate I thought that would be interesting
but then you have to think
okay you have to pay
for the flights of the people going you
have to like all these expenses add up
and when stuff gets demonetized
um it's very frustrating because
you know you might go negative on a
video so
like me dislikely agree with me disagree
with me censorship should not be the way
moving forward because
I don't even care if someone completely
is like a Die Hard feminist I respect
their right to talk about what they
think and I respect their right to
believe what they believe and make
videos on what they believe and I just
think that it's so one-sided where one
side of the coin is constantly censored
where the other side of the coin can
just say what they want
um
so
yeah that was that was like behind the
scenes the video and why go south second
one
also guys I'm sorry I know my my bed's
messed up in my hotel room I don't make
Hotel Beds sue me you know what I mean
but
constantly call me
grifter and I was really confused when I
first got in the space I was like what
the hell is a grifter
and so I Googled it I'm a googler you
know what I mean I'm let me let me just
to make sure I got it right the
definition of a grifter
grifter definition
um a person who engages in Petty or
small scale swindling
fraud and I was thinking about it and
I'm like a fraud what do I sell
what do I
now don't get me wrong I'm thinking
about selling a YouTube course
um
foreign
and I'm also thinking
about selling merch I think I had merch
at one point but
look it I'm not saying I'll never sell
anything but I was like if you're gonna
call me a fraud
or a grifter
and then I was like okay what else could
I be a fraud on
and I'm like everyone saw me getting red
pilled on camera that was how I started
I was doing reaction video you can see
me getting red pilled live and then you
know what's funny everyone thinks my
show blew up the channel nah nesky NADA
that was not the turning point of the
channel my number one viewed video for
the longest time
um and honestly probably before this
like well I got demonetized but what
probably my most profitable video was I
red pilled my friend for the first time
and it was like me showing her Jordan
Peterson that was what took off the
channel so I was like
I swindled people on a reaction
I put I put people on a show to talk
about relationships
huh
well you know you can't you can't win
them all so I was just like whatever but
I just thought it was interesting
because
for a while I don't even know what that
was and I was like if you guys are gonna
call me that you better go talk to the
people with 800 courses on how to DM
women I'm not going to say names
but I'm I'm just and I personally I
think you should be able to do that I'm
just saying to the people calling me
grifter whatever you should talk to them
first
first
um
so
it's like maybe I should start if I'm
gonna get called in anyway maybe I
should just start selling I could sell
sweatshirts grifter on it
I'm so sick I'm sick um okay
another thing that I got
from the show I was watching back the
show with um
the Andrew Tate panel it's such a
beautiful piece of content I'm really
proud of that one like honestly I just
thought
again when I put together panels I'm
always looking for two people on the end
of the opposite Spectrum where they can
debate and the audience can decide that
that's always my goal if I can get two
people that disagree
the more educated the better
the more or the more vehemently they
believe what they believe the better so
I'm I'm proud of that one I just I think
it was a good video good idea and I was
watching it back and
this girl was talking about she needs a
man to handle you
ladies ladies let's talk about this
no man wants to handle you I didn't talk
about this as much as I wanted to
because there's a big panel a lot of
people talking
no guy wants to come to work and come
home and be his bitch's emotional tampon
okay I'm sorry no God wants to come home
and is like you know what I can't wait
to handle my girl and the guys that do
like that you know what I I misspoke
there's a couple guys they do like toxic
women they do like these crazy women but
typically those mom those men this is
just what I've seen they're trying to
date their mothers and usually their mom
was a conniving whatever and two the
guys that do like those toxic women
the ones that do
they're usually bombs they got nothing
better
than better talking about how these guys
that she dates don't like do anything
they're just on their video games I'm
like lady
of course
you need a guy to handle that means
you're toxic
and the bombs like that not the men with
jobs
not the men that go go to work
but yes you can go find yourself a nice
bum
and he will handle you
I'm like what is society coming to and
it was crazy that girl on the podcast
that is the most self uh not self-aware
girl I have ever seen in my life I have
I have top five in terms of delusion
top five and Esther if you're watching
this sorry but I stand on it I stand on
that
this girl's talking about this girl's
talking about
how Auntie Jenny's being rude I'm like
and how
I made her like I said why are you over
talking everybody on the last show she
was on and I was rude for telling her to
stop over talking people on my show
I was just like
this this girl's crazy I feel bad for
whoever dates you you should go to
therapy and I'm not even trying to be
rude I'm just saying genuinely if I was
your dating coach now I know before
everyone comes for me Pearl can't be a
dating coach
okay I'm not I'm not okay so you can
take this or leave it you know
um
but if I was if I was
I would say start with therapy because
you are so not self-aware you need a
therapist to just tell you about
yourself and I think a lot of therapists
make people worse
but personally I would send her to a
male therapist a male
my sister is going to be a female
therapist and I told her I was like that
that school is just gonna make you crazy
they're gonna psychoanalyze everything
I'm like I don't think women are meant
to be therapists I really think it's a
man's job
I know I know
I know everyone's gonna come for me you
sexist just just what I've seen third
thing
third I'm all over the place I just got
thoughts I feel like I have not done
enough of these morning coffee thoughts
so I can just tell you my thoughts on
society third thing okay
I was trying to think of how do you come
up with an opinion right because there's
studies
that you can look at right and I always
like to think you have to look at
studies right so you look at something
in the world you see is this true look
at some studies but honestly really
and this is coming from someone that
uses a lot of stats
all studies
all studies can be made to like say damn
near anything
wasn't there some study that got
published like talking about sexism in
dogs and like these guys were trolling
but like literally and so I'm like you
know what
no I understand there's ways around this
there's ways that you can make it more
reputable
but the way I look at it is you can have
a study that says two plus two equals
four
and I look around and I see two plus two
equals 4. now someone else could say
well this study says 2 plus 2 equals 5.
the most reputable study on the planet
but if I look outside
and two plus two still equals four even
with the study I'm gonna believe two
plus two equals four and then
let's try to overthink it they're like
oh you have confirmation bias
I I wouldn't even say confirmation bias
hold on guys I need tissue I'm sick
um
foreign
I wouldn't even say you could say that
you know
I think there's a level of Common Sense
and that's the problem with the red pill
there's a lot of stuff
that you know when I first listened to
I was like no I was triggered you can
look at my early stuff I was triggered
and I've always been conservative but
I'm like the more
the cheating stuff I was triggered
breaking up homes if he cheats I was
like yeah leave his ass like you know
but
the problem with the red pill
is it is the truth
and it's true and it talks and like even
when they're talking about like women
love bad boys
and I I swear to God I was watching this
content so I know we don't dating a guy
that my parents hated
no okay and I hate it because whenever I
talk about anything dating
people always are like they're just so
quick to come for me they're like and I
was thinking about it and I'm like I'm
and like they'll say well women love
drama and then I was thinking no I don't
that's the Miami girls and then I had to
think about it and I'm like well why
would I say in that relationship that
was full of drama there's part of you
that likes it and it's not to say
that you'll like it forever and you
won't get sick but
the whole point of the red pills there
are General truths about women and men
in society
and then you know the super left ear
like the anti-red pill will just say oh
you're just saying that like what are
the kind of women like like they'll kind
of be like
trying to think of how about phrase it
though they'll first say that
okay you
know I'm trying to explain this they'll
first try to rip apart your studies and
be like that study doesn't work for that
that and the study really just has two
plus two equals to four it really just
says two plus two equals four they're
like well that study doesn't work that
and the thing is it's weird they'll try
to disqualify them even if they're I
would say reputable but
two plus two equals four
and then you'll look around and be like
well
I don't even really need to study to
like
women watch the Kardashians men watch
basketball women we like drama to some
level some women more than others right
but again that's just two plus two
equals four men cheat more than women
when given the chance and it's
like if men had a Bus full of and this
is where I was triggered because I was
like my dad doesn't cheat my dad doesn't
my dad is a great man I would be very
and everyone will say oh he cheats and
you don't know I would be very surprised
if my dad cheated on my mom I don't I
don't think he would do that
um
and everyone will be like well he's got
a mistress like someday you'll find he
might you know
um but
the point they make is that if my dad
had a Bus full of models waiting for him
when he got back every day he would have
a hard time staying faithful
it would be hard so some guys do it
and that was that was the whole point of
the red pill and the more you listen the
more you're like you know what
that's just true and two plus two equals
four and that's my opinion on the red
pill it just talks about two plus two
equals four and it's not really about
what you should do
um
I know you know and then they'll be like
well Kevin Samuels had that one stream
high value men should cheat and I'm like
okay you're gonna go with the title
did you listen to his streams
but
yeah so that's like sometimes they just
argue to argue it's just like two plus
two equals four and you can try to make
two plus two equals five all you want
but two plus two still equals four
yeah
um
oh my gosh you guys see how sick I am
this is not good
so
that's my two cents for the day that's
my coffee thought
let me know what you guys think in the
comments I know I'm So Random I just
talk about random [ __ ]
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel bring that
notification Bell I'll talk to you next
time